so I'm going to talk about something
called equivocal when we do predictive
modeling I wrote I thought I'd finish
these slides and then I saw the about
meas so statistician I've worked in like
the diagnostic industry which I'll talk
briefly about pharmaceuticals I worked
at our studio now doing mostly modeling
packages sort of in the order of the
ones that I've released I mean they're
all here in a couple books not a hot dog
and yeah that's my dog who you can see
the treats lying next to her coming back
from her walk which she's I think I was
making like a hamburger and that's
looking yeah so anyway all right so I
want to talk about some particular stick
to the statistical methods you use in
the diagnostic industry and then how
they might be applied and in certain
circumstances not universally but in
certain circumstances when you're doing
just general modeling so you know I had
this job and one of the jobs that I did
was the algorithms for instruments which
means like you get like a really bad
cough and you go into the doctor and you
know you cough up speed them sample or
they like typical your throat sorry more
huh you know you give them a sample and
then they put it in some diagnostic
instrument and it gets you a signal back
and the signal is you know high probably
if you have some like let's say
tuberculosis right in low if you don't
and so you usually get data it looks
like this where the samples that are
negatives have you know a fairly low
signal distribution but a long tail and
then you have some positives here that
on average are higher and then like one
of the final jobs the statistician would
do in that case would be what's my
actual cutoff like above what number
here do I say somebody's in actual
positive and so typically you would use
what's going to ROC curve or receiver
operating characteristic curve analysis
and you know that would look what that
lets you do is balance like how many
false negatives versus how many false
positives and that kind of thing and you
might come off come up with a cut-off
here so the samples to the right or the
negatives would be false positives and
your host negatives are down here but
what FDA would requires to do is put
something in their code into equivocal
zone which means like you know if this
cutoff is let's say two point
if you had a value of 2.71 they're like
yeah maybe not a positive even though
it's past your cutoff and so we had to
do all the sensitivity analysis and
things like that based on other data
sets and come up with what they call an
equivocal zone in the equivocal zone in
this particular instance would just be
like a buffer around your cutoff that
you determined with data that would
optimize really the performance of the
assay or the lab test and we tried I
mean you could make this performance
really good by making it really wide so
we had to balance off you know samples
we exclude so we had what we call a
reportable rate like you know anything
that's inside this equivocal zone you
would not actually report the value to
the patient you would say hey run the
assay again or collect a new sample you
know where it's so close we don't think
we can make a call between positive and
negative okay so we had to balance the
what we call the reportable rate which
is the number of patient samples that
you actually give to people versus
performance okay and that was just
something we had to do and it seems like
kind of like a dodgy thing if you're a
statistician because you're saying hey
take the ones like you're most likely to
miss and just get rid of those in your
analysis but at the very end I have a
link to an FD IFD eight guidance for
that so it's like a real thing that they
would sort of make us do whether we
wanted to do or not but again these are
the ones that you're most likely to miss
and you actually when you do the
analysis you would get rid of any
samples that are within the equivocal
zone okay so the idea is you know when
do we when we're especially we're
predicting something very important
there are situations where we might not
want to make a prediction right I mean
we can take whatever data we have and
funnel it through our model and get a
number but then we have to question like
wage and I get that number to somebody
is there is there any criteria in which
I shouldn't do that and that's kind of
what the the previous equivocal
equivocal zone was doing is we think
that there's these samples are
problematic not because of what their
true answer is but because of the value
we're getting before we see the transfer
okay I'm so like an unsupervised rule
that would make you exclude data you
think are not good enough for
predictions and so you know and this
comes into playing these things called
applicability domain so I used to work a
lot in computational chemistry and this
is really big they're like if you build
in pharma a lot of times and drug
discovery we'd both these
to make predictions on new potential
drugs right what we call compounds in
these compounds a lot of times would be
something that a chemist would design on
their computer and would not actually
exist
you know IRL and then we would take
those formulas that they come up with
and make predictions on whether it's
toxic or whether it's permeable and all
these things that chemists want to know
right so if you have a model you've
built for let's say toxicity and it
involves like a thousand data points a
thousand compounds and then you have a
new compound that looks nothing like the
ones that you've built your model on you
might flag that as not being applicable
like it's so different from the data was
used to build your model you might not
want to make a prediction on that no
matter what the actual value of the
prediction is okay and so these are
situations again if you're predicting
something like patient response like you
want to make sure you have a really
definitive understanding of what the
results should be from the model maybe
before you give that result to like a
patient because the consequences are
potentially dire so so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to show an example of
from drug discovery and all you need to
know about it is there's this thing
called mutagenicity which is when you
take a drug and actually or you ingest
anything really and it damages your DNA
which I don't think I need explained is
like not a good thing right
I mean you won't grow like a second hat
or anything like that almost never and
but means anticipating we want to avoid
there's this thing called a lab test
called the Ames test and gives you back
like a yes or no answer and so we have
like a standard data set that we use it
has about about 4,300 data points and
then there's a lot of predictors there's
actually about 1,500 predictors but
they're mostly extremely correlated and
we have some ways of Willing that down
to about you know 80 some predictors so
what we want to do is we want to build a
model to make predictions on compounds
as to whether they're toxic or not this
particular kind of toxicity and then how
could we use an equivocal zone to maybe
filter out some predictions that were
not really quite sure about but we
should give to the chemist and in this
particular case like you know it's hard
to give bad news to people and if you
say hey you know I think there's like a
90% chance that your compounds gonna
like hurt somebody you know they're very
conscientious but they're like prove it
right so this is a situation where like
we called something equivocal than what
we would say is hey well let's look at
this particular structure
and see if it's really related to
existing structures or compounds that we
know are dangerous and things like that
so what we would do in equivocal
situation here from a model would be
tell the chemist to go back and just
gather more data or run it in a more
definitive lab screen or something more
to get better data instead of accepting
what this particular model would say
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to fit a logistic regression which
you probably are all familiar with but
I'm gonna do a Bayesian logistic
regression and if you're not really
familiar with Bayes methods basically
what we do is we take the the beta
parameters in our logistic regression
and before we do any data analysis or
modeling we put what we call prior
distributions which is it's a
statistical distribution saying what we
think you know absent of any data what
we think those parameters should be and
what's pretty typical in a model like
this is if you think about like the the
predictors being centered and scaled we
put a really really wide normal
distribution on these parameters like
like a standard deviation of 10 or a
mean of zero right super super wide
prior distribution and then what Bayes
rule does is it mixes the the prior and
the data that you have in your data set
come up with something called the
posterior and the posterior mostly looks
like the prior a lot of times when your
data is very small or weak but if you
have a lot of data and very let's say a
precise data then the output of your
Bayesian analysis this posterior
distribution tends to look a lot more
like the empirical data that you have so
Bayes rule is really good at coming up
with a mixture of your prior
distribution in your observed data to
create this in color posterior right so
what we do is when we get we fit our
model in this particular case and we get
predictions like we would from any other
religious aggression like here's the
probability that this particular
compound is toxic I can't want to say
not a hot dog thanks David
so we're gonna get it like a class
probability out of this and and just to
remind you if you remember back from
like your old school statistic days when
you had to actually look at binomial
distributions that the rates parameter
of a binomial distribution has a
variance that if the rate was P the
variance is P times 1 minus P right so
just keep that in mind that relationship
there because we'll come back
to it so so one cool thing about base
analysis is even though my prediction is
an actual number like a probability of
it being toxic we actually what we do is
that posterior general distribution is
actually a distribution around the
probability so we have a probability
distribution on a probability estimate
basically and so what that allows us to
do is to get a measure of uncertainty so
if I tell you a compound had a
probability of being toxic is like 93
0.4 plus or minus you know 0.001 that's
a very precise prediction but it lifts
it's much wider than that you know we
can get that estimate in a Bayesian
analysis which we can't really get in
ordinarily disk regression easily at
least okay so what I did is um I used a
10-fold cross-validation and the plots
I'll show you the predictions in a
minute or the holdout samples from
10-fold cross-validation right so I'm
not involving a testing or anything
right now and one last little note about
this is there are a lot of other models
besides like some fancy Bayesian model
that you can get these types of interval
estimates for predictions so like
there's a recent paper for let's say
random forests where it shows how to
take a random forest prediction and then
get a what we call a it's kind of like a
confidence interval for the the
predicted value so it's not the only way
you could have done this so this plot on
the x axis is the probability of being
toxic and now the y axis is our
uncertainty around that prediction which
I've just called a standard error here
so all I did is each one these data
points has a posterior distribution
around its prediction the points are on
the x-axis or the mean of that
distribution and the points on the
y-axis are the standard deviation of the
posterior so it's sort of like our
standard deviation of our predicted
value okay in the dotted line going from
left to right that's basically a
multiple of P times 1 minus P and so
that gives us a sense of what like our
average level of uncertainty is for each
of these compounds and you can see some
of them are below the line which means
that they're more precise than what we'd
expect on average but then we have some
that are actually pretty flagrantly high
you know like here then up here and so
one thing about this is hopefully the
color comes across well as you can see
you know thankfully more of our red is
to the right of 0.5 that
the models you know working because
they're being predicted as a toxic
compound but you see some high flyers
here and there so you see you know even
when we come down to the things that
we're very confidently predicting not to
be toxic you see a couple of toxic ones
here that have a much higher variation
like up here than others so even when
you get a very confident prediction it
can have a large amount of uncertainty
around it okay so let's take an example
let's look at something that was
predicted to be really really very
strong probability meet toxic we have
one that's way up here in terms of its
variation and then I'm going to take one
that sort of in the mass here it has
very low variation let's look at like
well wait how does that happen
so let's look at the posterior
distribution distribution of those two
samples and so they're both predicted
probability about point nine four point
three point four they come from
different folds and cross foundation and
although that's not the particular
reason that they're different but if you
look at the posteriors over here what
you see is you have this one number 2509
that has a pretty tight distribution
around 94.3 and then you see this other
one was at 128 that is really really
confident that it's toxic except when
it's not really and it feels really you
know moderately confident that it's not
toxic so you have this like this really
polarized bathtub sieve distribution for
your posterior and it's like it's like a
very like very bipolar prediction and so
the uncertainty this is why the
uncertainty estimate is so high because
you know it really does think it's toxic
except when it doesn't and this to me is
like a problematic prediction the
variation around this prediction so high
then maybe we don't report this one
right this would be reason that we would
go back to our chemist and say yeah I I
know what the probability says but I
just don't feel right about this
prediction let's not use this value or
in fact I think we'd probably not even
give them the probability number we
would just say yeah this this
probability prediction wasn't very good
right so how can we label these as being
equivocal okay so we need to set up some
rules to take the output of our
classification model and decide which
ones we're going to actually give the
the consumers of this model which ones
we're not going to now one reason this
could happen is extrapolation so if this
compound represented by the blue
histograms here was something was really
really different
the D that was used in the model like if
you think about like your old linear
aggression class where we showed like
confidence intervals across the
prediction remember how they like to
sort of flare out at the ends right
that's uncertainty and that's
uncertainty due to extrapolation and my
feeling is for this particular example
this compound is very much an
extrapolation compared to what was used
to build a model and that's why it's
posterior distribution so Janke is the
technical term it's not
don't use that and when you're talking
your boss that's really janky yeah
anyway so what we're gonna do is we're
it come up with basically two rules the
first rule is going to be sort of like I
show at the very beginning where if we
have things that are around point five
let's maybe not report them because
they're sort of equivocal we can't
really decide if they are you know close
enough to the line to call it a toxic
compound or not and the other thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna try to
find a rule that will flag the compounds
that have really high variation right
but high variation means something
different on this end of the scale as it
is this end of the scale so we have have
to have something that says you know for
a probability around 0.3 the variation
can't be above a certain value and that
value would be different that if the
probability was like 0.001 okay so the
way I've chosen to solve this here is to
come up with basically you know plus or
minus around 0.5 and then basically we
estimate the standard error basically
using this line here and come up with a
multiplier there so if you're let's say
and I just eyeballed this to be honest
with you if you were like about seventy
five percent more variable than the
average compound we think that's
probably too variable for me to report
the actual value so if you look at if
you take this plot and apply that rule
we come up with what I on Twitter refer
to is the buck tooth mustache plot and
that looks like this alright so like so
okay so let me explain this the red line
is kind of the rule so if we have things
around plus or minus 0.5 we don't want
to report those so they're above the
lines so these would be called equivocal
for that for that level of buffer right
and then things you know down here these
would be reported equivocal even though
they have very strong probability values
the uncertainty is far enough about then
front of larger than other samples
around its value for me to feel safe and
make
predictions so then the question is like
we'll wait max how did you come up with
these numbers and so these would be
basically tuning parameters for the
model where you want to optimize your
equivocal zone such that it gives you a
good a better performance but not so
much that you're excluding almost all
predictions so you'd probably want to
before you do this come up with a number
that says you know we never want to
exclude more than 5% of the values that
come out of this model right so so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
how that works I'm gonna leave the the
the mustache part of this plot alone for
a little bit and then just look at the I
don't believe I'm saying this the
buck-toothed Park okay I'm the same guy
who made juice and our in our function
so I don't think that's for what it's
worth but I'm gonna see you know as we
vary the size of the buck-toothed here
how that affects performance so if I if
I start with zero that means like I'm
not excluding anything because there's
no buffer around 0.5 and then the
numbers on the next plot basically show
on the x-axis how wide that that part of
the equivocal zone is getting and not
performance changes and I use the area
of the RC curve to to do this so if you
start off with a with basically no
buffer but with the the mustache part of
the equivocal zone we start off with 100
per so in this panel it's the number
that you report out so we report out
almost 100% of our samples with no
additional equivocal zone and our
performance goes immediately from 0.85
to around
I'm sorry point 835 to around 84 to rate
for 3 so we get a you know an immediate
jump in our performance without losing
many samples to being equivocal and that
is simply because that's the ones above
the the must the mustache part of the
plot okay
and so as we increase the width of that
buck-toothed part you can see the report
wear rate is going down so around here
we're only reporting about 95 percent of
results and then you can see it like
literally decreases which makes sense
and then you can see performance sort of
at a different rate increases in terms
of its airing of the RC curve right and
of course you can keep whining this or
not making it wide enough you would
probably choose how wide you want to
make it probably more based on the
reportable rate by how many you
don't want to make predictions for then
probably the area near the rc4 because
every time I've done this I've almost
always had a linear increase in
performance so it's not like it really
tops out at somewhere so anyway this is
what I typically see and again this is a
tuning parameter so if you wanted to do
this you don't want to have some
optimality criterion by saying like you
mean the best thing to the RC curve
under the condition that I always report
at least 90% of my data or something
like that okay and just so you know like
when I did this in Diagnostics we would
actually have a separate R&D trial that
collected like a thousand data points
only to do this part of the analysis ok
so if you are going to use data to make
a decision about what this should be and
either have a separate data set to do it
or include it inside of your resampling
procedure all right so so how can you do
this I have a package that I sent to
cran and it's not yet approved it's been
about a week called parsnip and that
helps with the modeling part here and
then we have a package I hope to put on
cran before the year called probably
which I think the sticker is gonna be
May
it probably has the best of the
equivocal zone and so what parsnip would
do is it would enable you to fit this
like Bayesian logistic regression or
hereis or you know glim net or whatever
kind of logistic regression you want to
use with minimal syntax it's kind of
like the unified interface part of
carrot but more tidy and so if you
wanted to do that you would load the
parse in a package you tell it you want
to do logistic regression and then the
engine is like the package or the the
computational engine you want to use so
if you wanted you Stan
you set the computational engine the
stand and then if there's any sustain
specific criteria or arguments you want
to use you can add them here so so those
posterior distributions were based off
of said four chains each of 2000 but you
cut out a half of them so it's about
4000 data points are in those posterior
distributions and those come from me
saying the number of chains here right
and then fit just fits that model right
so the syntax here is very concise and
it's almost identical if you were using
gloom net or curious or GLM or whatever
code you want to use to fit the logistic
regression and then a little bit to make
the equivalents here's what we did is we
the predict method will give you your
values and then what we have is we have
a data structure call a think it's
called a class under our print objects
which is basically like a factor but it
wouldn't allows you to do is inside the
factories mark which elements of that
vector should be called equivocal so it
doesn't add like enum another layer to
the factor it just it's an additional
attribute that we keep along and when
you convert that class spread object to
a factor an actual factor like when you
want to calculate accuracy or whatever
it actually takes all the equivocal
values in mark some is n/a right so you
don't actually even though they get
stored in the data when you convert back
to a factor to do your analysis it marks
the equippable is n/a okay and if you
had an n/a going in that's just one more
n/a that was maybe not equivocal that
gets added to list of entities when you
convert to factor right so so it handles
the equivocal is in a sensible way and
they're consistent with what you would
do in our and it also means like if you
want to do your analysis on any of these
data you don't have to have like a
special like accuracy or precision or
recall function to handle these
equivocal samples just also happens for
you and the syntax you might expect is
very deep liar consistent so so yeah
it's all stuff we're building and
hopefully it'll be done by or at least
I'm crammed by the end of the year
depending on some other package that are
being released so in summary you know
there are times in a model where you
don't want to make predictions based not
on what the predicted value is itself
maybe but the quality of the prediction
so maybe it's again too close to the
cutoff or maybe there's something else
about the prediction like its amount of
extrapolation or some like that that
would make you and say yeah let's not
give somebody a number in those
instances and you need to balance you
know how you make something quick all
you need to balance the performance and
what we call the reportable rate just to
make sure you're not excluding all but
the most obvious samples from your model
and then we have packages that are in
process for this here's a link to the
FDA guidance one of the many FDA
guidance to talks about the cocoa zones
and here's a length of the paper and
they have their data in a supplemental
file although we have in our package
with
and that is it
[Applause]